foreign  [Music]  I'm up with you  [Music]  I think it's probably hit us now with my  singing The Anthem and everything we're  just like you can't really hold the  emotions back anymore  [Music]  oh yeah  [Music]  through second thing  Queen Elizabeth II provided us with the  stability and the strength that we  needed  she was the very Spirit of Great Britain  and that spirit will endure  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  for all of you  she was a great baby  so delighted we got to meet her Queen  Elizabeth II is the only reigning  monarch most of us have known and the  only one to ever visit Australia in  a complicated world  her steady Grace and resolve  brought comfort and strength to us all  [Music]